في هذا الحي الفقير بمنطقه وادي الليل
بمحافظه منوبه جريمه جديده تحدث وتهز
الراي العام حيث اقدم رجل على قتل زوجته
تعلن وحاول قتل لبنته الكبرى تموت الام
مخلفه اربعه اطفال قصر ويكون مصير الوارد
السجن والمحصله تفكك عائله اخرى غير بعيد
من الموت بعد ما اقتلع زوجها عينيها
اثنتين وتعنها في مناطق حساسه من جسمها
حكاياتها واطفالها الاربعه القصر كما
ترويها لنا
رجلها عينيها زوز خليف يعني ضربه اللي في
وجهي فما عون فيه خزانه في وجهي في جسم
زياده في مناطق حساسه هناك امراه يعني
متصالحه مع نفسي
تصالحت مع نفسي
وطالبه مسكن ولادي
شهيده تونس الى حدود شهر اكتوبر المنقذي
15 جريمه قتل ضد النساء والف حالات عنف
المادي والمعنويه ما هذا الراي العامه في
البلاد
تحت شعار النساء
هما اللي ماتوا واللي يمثلوا فمنسي مهديت
بالقتل في اي لحظه في اي لحظه اي ضحيه
عنفت نجمه متولي للاسف مرحومه ورغم ان
القانون يفرز على الدوله تامين الحمايه
للمعنفات علاوه على توفير الرعايه الصحيه
والنفسيه في مواجهه ظاهره العنف لان
تقريرا رسميا كشفا ان الاطار الاسريه بات
فضاءا حاضنا للعنف وتحولت البيئه الاسريه
الى بيئه غير امنه
تعددت اسباب قتل النساء
الا انها تبقى جرائم صادمه في مجتمع ان
يؤكد المختصون تراجع منسوبي القيم
الانسانيه فيه مؤخرا في انتظار حلولا من
دوله تباهي بريادتها في مجال حقوق المراه
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس